when you first came out what year was it
like on a major label 2015. so 2015 the
landscape of being a female rapper quote
unquote is way different way different
and then Queen Nick and yeah shout out
to Nikki yeah and then there was uh what
2015. there wasn't a lot of female
rappers deje Dej Loaf she was like 2014.
you know but yeah it was definitely
tough because it and it kind of there
was like this female Renaissance if you
will around 2017 2018 where it was like
and I I look at music currently
specifically hip-hop there's like a lack
of real records in rap right now like if
you really think about
like what has been the smash this year
that you go to the club and it's like
automatic like there's to play for
sure there's to play but
the days I just there's not like like
these dudes ain't making anthems no more
like uh now glorilla is making a
Anthem you know what I'm saying like I
love me some glorella like Megan's
making real records you know what I mean
um coil array the player's record
is a dope that's a hit it's a hit you
know what I mean I just feel like dudes
are just like kind of like women are
taking over to be honest I have I have
more of the girls rapping than I do with
the guys and they're making just better
songs absolutely and we we know our
audience too like you know women are
speaking for women so yeah you know do
you feel like uh you should have got
nominated for a Grammy
uh
I don't want to say that now I think you
know I'm really hard on myself I'm a
hard critic so I got a lot of work to
put in still right
um and like I say I'm really just
getting my foot in that door again yeah
so um with time and I don't really make
music to like be nominated nowhere I
feel like you know if it happens it
happens if it happens it happens and I'm
grateful
but um you know that's not like the end
all
right for sure like so many artists that
never really got there yeah got their
Grammy or got their Awards but uh I mean
Nas barely just won a Grammy last year
and it was like 20 25 years later after
him yeah
it's crazy yeah no so yeah